[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alan shipnot has been covering golf for
sports illustrated 25 years on the beat
and
he has a book filled the rip roaring and
unauthorized biography of golf's most
colorful superstar available online
wherever books are sold
why do you think the live tours already
won versus the pga tour along
it's slightly more nuanced than that dan
but they definitely have
um
taken a lot of turf here and
uh you know there's more players coming
and there's some big names coming and
there's a critical mass of major
championship winners hall of famers
big time personalities they just can't
be ignored anymore
in the marketplace
you know as as golf fans even though the
competition does not stir the soul um
there's too much energy here now and the
tour is hemorrhage too much star power
there's really not enough players in
golf that we care about to sustain two
tours
barely enough for one tour and you start
splitting up these guys um the pj tour
has promised a certain product to its
fans and its advertisers and they
they've lost a lot of the players that
drive the tour and so um
it's at some point a concession is gonna
have to be made and this notion that
the the major championships are gonna
freeze out
um the lib players is nonsensical i mean
there's just too many past champions
there's too many
big time players i mean the majors get
the spotlight one week a year they want
the best field possible they want their
past champions and then the other line
of defense for the tours maybe
liv won't get world ranking points but
again are you giving world renting
points to the corn fairy tour with a
bunch of like college kids and old
timers no one's ever heard of and you're
not going to give it to this tour that
has a bunch of big time players it makes
no sense so
the um those those are the kind of the
last stands for the tour the majors in
the world ranking but i think they're
gonna lose both those battles and then
they're gonna have to they're gonna have
to cut some sort of uh sort of deal to
bring to bring the game back together in
one piece well congratulations first of
all getting credentialed because that's
a big step for you didn't you uh you get
thrown out of a tournament earlier this
year
yeah well the first the first live event
in london and that was phil mickelson's
return to public life and um
i had i'd recently published a biography
about phil nicholson and
it was not the live folks in the final
analysis who got me tossed
after doing snooping around and talking
a lot of people it seems very likely
that it was phil's own overprotective
management company and this little wormy
dude they employ who stick the security
goons on me so um it was a wild
overreaction but it's a funny story and
uh yes i was credentialed for that
tournament and there's only two
reporters now who've been to all three
events myself and bob harrigan um
it's not that i'm pro live i'm just
trying to understand what is a humongous
story in the sports world and there's a
lot of people on the sidelines who are
pontificating and pointing fingers and
shouting i'm actually trying to talk to
people and do some real reporting so
you're in jersey now you're at the the
trump bedminster golf course um can you
set the scene were there protests with
families from 9 11 victims out front
they weren't visible the way um that
that i came in you know this is really
trump likes to say this course is 20
minutes from the lincoln tunnel i mean
maybe if you have a helicopter it is we
are way out in the wilds of new jersey i
mean it's lovely rolling horse country
and there's biggest states and it looks
like a nice place to live but it is the
middle of nowhere and so there's just
these two lane country roads leading
into
the the course and they're never going
to let a protest happen in that space
it's too dangerous and so okay you know
i was i was at the u.s women's open here
when trump was a sitting president and
those protests then and they kind of
created a designated zone a couple miles
away which
was unsatisfying to the the protesters
they couldn't really be heard or seen
but it probably made sense from a safety
standpoint so i think it's gonna be the
same thing this week when you're on the
grounds you'll have no idea any of
that's happening you'll have to go find
them if you want to see the protesters
what is charles barkley's value the
potential for charles joining the value
for the live tour
and not much i think it's almost
negative because if they're trying to be
taken seriously as as a a real legit
golf tour
we all love charles barkley right but
he's kind of a sideshow he's not a golf
guy he's a bit of a court jester and he
adds entertainment value but i think it
actually hurts her credibility so
i think liv has gotten what they want in
this seduction they're in the headlines
charles is here playing the pro-am i saw
him on the range few minutes ago swing
looks decent
uh looks like the format is hokey
already with the live tour i mean
that so
charles can i add to the hokiness of it
yeah if you want to lean in on hokiness
but they want to be taken seriously so
that's why i don't think charles is a
good choice for them i mean they already
have david ferdi who has a wicked sense
of humor and he can he can entertain
fans but he's
you know a writer cupper and he's been
in the golf world for three decades as a
commentator like faraday brings a
certain star power but also a gravitas
that is woefully lacking with searle
charles despite his his lofty title so
um i don't
maybe they'll bring him in for a few
broadcasts just for comic relief but it
would be a monumental mistake to sign
him up for every every broadcast i think
the hardcore golf fans would be turned
off well he said that he was not given
an offer by norman when they went to
dinner and he was not told about a tv
partner although he told me earlier in
the week that there will be a tv partner
who are you hearing is going to carry
the live tour
that's a work in progress but that
that's
you know the the eyeballs will follow
the players and we know this in every
other sport like you're you're a lebron
james fan and you cheer for him no
matter when he switches jerseys and golf
has suddenly entered the 2020s right
where players are switching teams and
they're switching jerseys and
if you're a brooks kepca fan i'm sure
uh or phil mickelson fan or a bubba
watson fan who they just announced today
i'm sure they some people been turned
off because we know the where the money
is coming from on the lib tours makes
people uncomfortable and that's legit
but
uh ultimately you know the players are
their own franchises and i think that
that uh they're gonna you know the fans
will follow them to a large degree and
there will be a demand to watch them
play golf and
um you know therefore the network or
streaming service or both is going to
sign up
what do you make of the pga tour
strategy so far
it's been a mixed bag to say the least i
mean that uh you know monahan j monday
and the ptc commissioner was honest you
know we can't outspend these guys we
can't compete dollar for dollar everyone
knows that it's obvious so
what they've tried to they've had a
two-prong strategy one is to villainize
the saudis and the live tour and say
we're the we're the good guys and
they're the bad guys that's a losing
strategy the players have voted with
their feet like they don't care they're
taking the money like that's been made
obvious and that's been that's been the
case in golf for a very long time i mean
the european pj tour would have gone out
of business years ago without money from
china and saudi arabia and the united
arab emirates and qatar and without you
know autocratic oppressive regimes there
would be no european tour the players
made peace with that a long time ago so
the moral argument the tour has already
lost
uh they've now they've tried to lean on
tradition and the value of of history
and legacy and again a lot of players
have cut bait on that as well like
you know that they care about the majors
and they're still going to be able to
play the majors um there's not much
difference i think for a lot of these
guys from the greater hartford open and
a live event in portland and the phoenix
open and a live event in in new jersey
like it feels the same they're
professional golfers by definition they
play golf for money there's a hell of a
lot more money here so
um
so morality didn't work tradition didn't
work so
now you know what satoru has left that's
what they're trying to figure out
because i don't fault them that's kind
of all they had they can't outspend
these guys but um you know so far
they're out for two so we'll see what
they cook up next in ponte vedra beach
play nice there alan okay
thanks for joining us
yeah you got it thanks for having me all
right that's alan shipnock
been covering golf for a long time
i got credentialed again
so he wrote the book uh on phil and uh
seven other books there